the federal Commission on school safety
will hold its first public forum this
morning in Washington its chairman
Education Secretary Betsy DeVos caused a
stir at a Senate hearing yesterday when
she said the Commission is not
considering gun related safety issues we
judge Aang is also at the White House
this morning we said good morning good
morning John Secretary de Vos and the
administration argues that school safety
means much more than just gun control
but that commission was specifically
tasked with looking at a wide range of
solutions to address the problem of
school shootings and gun control was
certainly one of them it is a focus of
this administration Secretary Betsy
DeVos was grilled yesterday by
Democratic Senator Patrick Leahy
about how the federal school safety
commission is looking at the role of
guns and violence well your Commission
look at the role of firearms as it
relates to gun violence in our schools
that is not part of the Commission's
charge per se so you're studying gun
violence but not considering the role of
guns we're actually studying school
safety and how we can ensure our
students are safe and a spokeswoman
tried to clarify Davis's statement
saying the Commission is looking at all
the options tasked by the president
which originally included age limits on
firearms that Commission was created by
President Trump after a deadly school
shooting that took 17 lives on
Valentine's Day
in parkland Florida should have been one
school shooting and we should have fixed
it
parents pleaded and the president
promised to push new school safety
measures back in March the secretary
told 60 minutes school safety was an
urgent matter I have actually asked to
head up a task force that will really
look at what states are doing do you
feel a sense of urgency yes because this
sounds like talking know their service
enging there is a sense of urgency
indeed and recently the administration
has pointed to the Commission as a
solution
last week press secretary Sarah Sanders
held back tears after a
thirteen-year-old asked about preventing
school shootings
there is nothing that could be more
terrifying for a kid to go to school and
not feel safe so I'm sorry that you feel
that way the school safety commission
that the president convened is meeting
this week again an official meeting to
discuss the best ways forward that
public hearing for later today comes as
concerns mount over how effective this
commission really is the four person
group has only met a handful of times
and it does not plan to issue any kind
of report until the end of the year gale
all right we should got it thank you
very much